You're at memorial park,...
...a place where those who paid the ultimate price are never forgotten.
And on this day, that's a goal of dozens of people.
This way a little bit.
Their hands placing symbols of freedom in the grass,...
...row after row of red, white and blue.
On each flag, a name.
My brother died on 9/11.
He was in New York City.
Leonard Castrianno worked on the 105th floor of the World Trade Center's North Tower.
It fell at 9:28 in the morning, 13 years ago.
As the dust settled, there, rising out of the ashes, the American flag.
The same colors now dotting this lawn in Omaha, a real-life memorial.
Leonard's sister Lynn from Omaha has been doing this for ten years now.
And she's got some help.
I've been talking to some people and they're like going, "Oh, that's coming up."
So, people are already forgetting.
So, it's always a nice reminder for people to not to forget the tragedy that happened.
So, look at this field of 2,977 flags.
Always remember those we lost.
And from time to time, summon the strength of community...
...that came as our nation healed.